هذه هي الطريقه التي تدخل بها الى وضع
الوحش تعلم ضرب الكره من لاعب اتحاد كره
القدم الامريكيه مارشا
لش لكن هذا ليس مخيما في امريكا فكره
القدم الامريكيه في طريقها الى الخارج
جالبه معها الضرب والالم والدافع الفريده
من نوعه
تسمى كره القدم الامريكيه دون حواجز او اي
اف دبليو اختصارا حيث اقام عشره من لاعبي
كره القدم الامريكيه مخيما لثلاثه ايام في
مصر انها رياضه جديده ومختلفه عن ثقافتهم
لكنها ممتعه وهي التعريف الحقيقي لرياضه
الفريق والرياضه الجماعيه فهي تبني صداقات
تدوم مدى الحياه وهذا هو الامر الذي نريد
منهم العيش
كره القدم ليست غريبه في ارض الفراعنه
فمصر لديها بطولتي دوري والعديد من الفرق
المصريون يحبون الرياضات العنيفه قليلا
فهي جذابه لهم لذا عندما يرى الناس هذا
يقولون انها رياضه
[موسيقى]
عجيبه وفي غضون الساعات انضم 400 شخص
للتعلم من الافضل من ضمنهم فريقان
النسائي لدي حلم ض خصوصا للنساء في مصر
بان تزدهر رياضه كره القدم الامريكيه
هنا لكن هناك اكثر من مجرد الضرب
والتدريبات في كره القدم الامريكيه نريد
ان نثقل الرياضه حيال ما يتعلق بتناول
الطعام النظيف وان تكون صحيح الجسم عندما
تلعب هذه الرياضه يجب التاكد من ان لديك
المعدات المناسبه لان مثل هذه الرياضات لا
تمارس بالشكل الصحيح في البلدان الاخرى
ومن غير المحتمل ان تنتشر ملاعب كره القدم
الامريكيه في مصر في الوقت الحالي على
الاقل فكره القدم التقليديه لا تزال
الرياضه الاولى في مصر لكن من يدري قد
تعترض كره القدم الامريكيه الملاعب وتتصدر
الرياضات
هنا